I love you as an actor your character
though I have to say you have killed
more characters on the walking dead
people that I was really attached to you
a couple that and you've done it in the
most brutal way yeah and I have found
myself I will see billboards with your
face on it and I'll shout I hate that
guy
you're not alone I'm not that when
you're out in the world do especially
right when the character was introduced
I mean his introduction was obviously
tapping a couple folks on the head with
his baseball that was the character
though we got to meet him that way so
yeah for the first year this is my third
or fourth year on the show it was Ruffin
so whenever I go down the street people
are starting with the f-word going crazy
on me really and they were just unload
oh yeah yeah yeah and you've had the
experience of like hanging out with
other cast members and fans have been
nice to the other cast member is that
right yeah no I'm always Norman and I
spend a lot of Norman Reedus
yes yes Norman Reedus who plays Darryl
yeah we both ride motorcycles and we
spend a lot of time together off screen
and we go for long motorcycle rides in
and we were at one point we were in this
little town called noon and just having
a cup of coffee and people literally
will come by and they'll be like there
we love you and negan's mad and this
we're black and this this lady my
grandma's age just double fisted flipped
me off we're after like being like this
with Dara like I wanted I love you I
want to marry you most handsome man she
looks over at me and just gives me two
fingers and incredible yeah and I'm like
you know grandma yeah yeah come on I
know she's not your grandma oh my god no
you